qué hace un 52% de los votos a favor y
más de un millón de diferencia respecto
a la alternativa de quedarse el pasado
jueves 23 de junio el pueblo británico
determinó mediante referéndum a
abandonar la unión europea nada más
conocerse los resultados de un terremoto
en los mercados europeos que perdieron
en la jornada del viernes más de 300.000
millones de euros a un escenario de
pánico vendedor con caídas similares a
la quiebra de lehman brothers de entre
el 10 y el 15 por ciento en algunos
mercados europeos pero que ha llevado a
los británicos a tomar una decisión tan
drástica bien hoy aquí en visual
político queremos acercarnos a sus
razones porque nos lo habéis pedido y
también porque creemos que se ha
banalizado mucho desde los medios de
comunicación de habla hispana que han
achacado el resultado prácticamente sólo
la presencia de partidos y grupos
xenófobos cuando la realidad es mucho
más compleja no sólo la mayoría de
ciudadanos británicos han votado por la
salida sino que muchos de los líderes
políticos del reino unido- la apoyaban
entre ellos siete de los ministros del
gobierno moderado y proeuropeo de david
cameron incluso la canciller angela
merkel reconocía el pasado mes de
febrero que el reino unido tenía mucha
razón en muchos de los planteamientos y
demandas realizar
entre los partidarios del break si te
encontramos y a quienes están
obsesionados por los movimientos
migratorios y los problemas de
inmigración pero también a quienes
quieren reafirmar el libre mercado a las
islas e incluso a quienes desde la
extrema izquierda entienden que el presi
representa un punto de ruptura frente a
un modelo neoliberal que detestan
nosotros hoy nos vamos a centrar en las
principales razones que se han esgrimido
para defender la salida de la unión
europea
porque los británicos quieren el break
sí
la pertenencia a mercado único ha jugado
como no podía ser de otra forma un papel
clave en todo el proceso frente a las
amenazas los defensores del break sit se
han mostrado tajantes
razón número 1 el comercio el
proteccionismo y los aranceles
comunitarios la pac y las regulaciones
afectan gravemente al comercio británico
de hecho afirman que una vez que se
produzca la salida el reino unido no va
a tener ningún problema en llegar a un
acuerdo con la unión europea para
mantener su acceso al mercado único
porque afirman nadie en europa está
dispuesto a renunciar a los más de 500
mil millones de euros que cada año en
exportaciones van rumbo a la isla ojo
con un saldo positivo para la unión
europea de más de 180 mil millones de
dólares
además los partidos del break sheet
recuerdan que la economía británica cada
vez es menos dependiente del mercado
único y mucho más dependiente de
potencias extranjeras o de potencias
emergentes y de hecho afirman que la
salida les va a permitir diseñar
políticas comerciales para acceder en
mejores condiciones a este tipo de
mercados que tienen mucho más potencial
de hecho los partidarios de 'break' si
niegan que mayor integración equivalga a
mayor prosperidad y para ello utilizan
las estadísticas que demuestran que
cuanto más se han integrado los países
europeos más se ha desplomado su
crecimiento económico
y si tienen un modelo que se llama suiza
un país que no pertenece a la unión
europea y lo que en exportaciones per
cápitas multiplica por cinco al reino
unido cuyo pib per cápita es el doble
que el reino unido- y que tiene un
modelo de competitividad y de bienestar
que es uno de los más exitosos sin lugar
a dudas de todo el mundo
razón número 2 las regulaciones los
defensores del break si no sólo
consideran a las regulaciones
comunitarias como un ataque a su
soberanía sino que también entienden que
suponen un grave perjuicio para la
economía británica de hecho afirman que
tan solo el top 100 de regulaciones
supuso el año pasado un coste de más de
35 mil millones de euros para la
economía del reino y además tampoco
aceptan la incontinencia legislativa de
la comunidad europea que desde el año
2010 ha aprobado más de tres mil
quinientas leyes y reglamentos que
afectan a las empresas británicas
dificultando su capacidad para hacer
negocios y mermando su competitividad de
hecho como ejemplo de esta excesiva
regulación ponen sobre la mesa las 109
regulaciones que afectan a las almohadas
las 50 regulaciones sobre edredones y
sábanas o las 31 regulaciones que
detallan cómo tienen que funcionar los
mercados de cepillos de dientes y es que
incluso denuncian los partidarios de
bressi que la comunidad europea ha
regulado el tamaño de los kings
razón número 3 inmigración punto clave
la campaña sobre todo entre populistas y
nacionalistas los británicos quieren
controlar sus fronteras y de hecho
quieren implantar un sistema de
inmigración equivalente al de australia
es decir que dé prioridad a la
cualificación de los inmigrantes por
encima de otros criterios en los últimos
años hay que decir que la economía
británica ha marchado relativamente bien
de hecho el empleo se encuentra en las
cotas más altas de toda la historia con
lo que muchos inmigrantes han llegado a
las islas mira los números la migración
negra en reino unido- se acerca a su
récord y no tenemos ningún control por
parte de la unión europea tan solo mi
pasado año en términos netos más de 330
mil personas se desplazaron al reino
unido en busca de un trabajo y claro
esto ha sido aprovechado por grupos de
presión para generar un caldo de cultivo
nacionalista entre otras cosas por las
elevadas prestaciones sociales que
existen en este país y que generan un
efecto distorsionador enorme cuando
llegan de golpe muchos inmigrantes
razón número 4 transferencias a la unión
europea reunirse segundo donante neto de
la unión europea y su aportación insisto
en términos netos ronda los 200 millones
de euros semanales y hay que decir que
en las instituciones comunitarias ni por
supuesto su burocracia son ni han sido
nunca particularmente populares entre la
ciudadanía británica
de hecho ya desde los tiempos de wilson
y thatcher los británicos se han negado
específicamente a ser los paganinis de
la fiesta europea hay que decir que he
reunido accedió a la comunidad en 1973 y
ya en 1975 apenas dos años más tarde
habían planteando un referéndum para
modificar las condiciones de adhesión
por considerarlas injustas y fue poco
más tarde en 1979 cuando margaret
thatcher pronunció su célebre lado
es innegable que las instituciones
europeas no son un modelo de calidad
democrática y no lo digo sólo por la
dispersión y a lejanía del voto que
provoca su enorme extensión sino porque
en el día a día en la toma de decisiones
la opinión de los electores es
intrascendente
razón número 5 democracia la unión
europea es el paraíso de los burócratas
cuyas élites por cierto viven
prácticamente el anonimato y nunca se
sabe a ciencia cierta quién toma las
decisiones ni cómo se toman ni quién
influye en ellas claro en esta tesitura
no es difícil entender que para un
pueblo como el británico acostumbrado a
una democracia muy participativa donde
los ciudadanos conocen directamente a
sus representantes no les parezca muy
compatible esta pseudodemocracia con la
defensa de las libertades es hoy el
quién es usted ni yo ni nadie en europa
ha oído hablar nunca de usted quiero
preguntarle quién le votó para ser
presidente
hoy ponen vosotros qué pensáis del break
si creéis que se está abriendo un
periodo de cambio en la unión europea
pensáis que nuevos países seguirán los
pasos del reino unido en su aventura de
desconexión bueno si tiene mi opinión yo
soy contrario a presi pero porque soy
español si fuese británico no lo tendría
tan claro espero vuestros comentarios
para abrir un debate espero que os haya
gustado el vídeo un saludo y hasta la
próxima